so what do you say to those who say well
crypto just wasn't ready uh for the for
its moment when the market was crashing
it crashed as well
well firstly charles great to be back
thanks so much for having me on so look
bitcoin is definitely still that safe
haven asset nothing goes straight up and
in fact we don't want it to go straight
up because often when things do go
straight up they're followed by very
sharp snapbacks which will really hurt
retail investors what we want to see is
nice healthy corrections it's really
important to realize that bitcoin is
actually only 12 years old so this is
still a very immature market it's not
yet this uncorrelated asset so
geopolitics is still going to affect it
let's look at march 2020 for example
when covert took a hold of the world and
lockdown started we saw a major crash
bitcoin crashed from 8k down to 4k but
we didn't see the crypto winter which
everybody was expecting it then went on
to break new all-time highs continuing
by the way into 2021 becoming the best
performing asset compared to all other
traditional asset classes including gold
which is actually down nearly seven
percent year to date whereas bitcoin is
up roughly around 100 year-to-date and
if you take into account inflation which
is around 6.2
then really bitcoin is that obvious a
store of value that obvious safe haven
asset you really just have to zoom out i
don't understand how people can look at
gold anymore and really look at it as
that safe haven asset i had it had a
pretty good day friday but obviously i
get your point hey
to that uh to that in fact there's a lot
of speculation that one of the reasons
jack dorsey's bound guy to twitter uh
and maybe even eventually square is to
solely focus on crypto i mean how
bullish of a story would that be
well this is incredibly bullish because
i think one of the most fascinating
parts of this is that jack dorsey
actually said earlier in 2021 at the
bitcoin conference in miami that if he
was to leave twitter and square he would
then go full time into bitcoin so of
course we can expect him to do this i
think it's important to realize who jack
dorsey is jack dorsey is somebody who
spent 16 years dedicated to building
what is now essentially one of the most
important social media platforms in the
world it's totally revolutionized how we
use um how politics works how and the
media works how we work you and i met
through twitter for example so if he can
bring that level of expertise that
credibility and that energy into
building a bitcoin it's gonna be very
very bullish and just a really important
point to note here as well is that many
twitter users are very much dissatisfied
with the level of censorship that we
tend to see on twitter and so there is a
lot of hope that jack could actually
potentially build some form of
decentralized censorship resistant
version maybe on the bitcoin network
when we get to that point and from a
technical standpoint and then that could
actually bring all of those dissatisfied
twitter users into bitcoin opening
bitcoin up to an entirely new market you
know and i've spent some time with jack
i've had lunch with him and dinner and
uh you know i think he also sees it
probably as a way to help the rest of
the world you know the the
underdeveloped countries not have to go
through the imf in other ways to get on
track hey i got less than a minute to go
so i need a shorter answer but i need
one from you on the ecb chief christine
lagarde over the weekend saying that
bitcoin that's not a currency what are
your thoughts
okay bitcoin is obviously a currency i
get paid 100 in bitcoin politicians are
getting paid in bitcoin um you have an
entire nation el salvador which is
getting paid in bitcoin to say that is
very ignorant and i believe and she i
think the saddest point was she didn't
really give a reason behind this um she
just sort of said it and i believe she
feels this way because she realizes as
the president of um the european central
bank that bitcoin has the ability to
dismantle the establishment because what
it can do is disintermediate the
government disintermediate central banks
and when you don't really need the
government you don't really need central
banks they have less control and less
power you know we got to work leia on
getting you out your shell to get you to
you know the kind of be a little bit
more
passionate about things and then speak
directly and not be afraid uh in the
meantime thank you so much and we'll
talk to you again real soon
thanks charles all right folks at a
holiday shopping season